elle s'annonçait violente la tempête
xynthia frappé fort la nuit dernière
faisant plusieurs morts on y reviendra
dans un instant et d'importants dégâts
la charente maritime a été
particulièrement touchée à n'diaye paix
alain darrigrand ils n'ont que leurs
bras pour ida cuit cette femme âgée
après la tempête
tout le quartier et inondées et les
pompiers sont débordés et alors on
s'aide entre voisins bah je sors
monsieur qu'on est hors de l'ombre un
show bien après ben moi je suis retourné
chez moi sauver le seul faute à quelques
kilomètres de là on emploie les grands
moyens pour évacuer les campings
totalement inondé une montée des eaux
qui a surpris les campeurs dans leur
sommeil
au milieu de la nuit la mer déchaînée
est passé par dessus les digues les
rafales de vent dépasse les 130 140 km
heure le port de la rochelle disparaît
sous les flots les bateaux se retrouve
au dessus des voitures et les piétons
dans l'eau en fait c'est très dangereuse
qu'on a surtout peur des bouches d'égout
rhin s'est pas trop on marche on va
c'est assez inquiétant on n'a jamais vu
là aussi haute
on n'a jamais vu l'eau atteint ce niveau
là pourtant des automobilistes
s'aventure ils sont rapidement pris au
piège et certains veulent à tout prix
récupérer leur véhicule
non pour l'instant voilà ça peu la
panique la sur le port nous sommes
rentrés de mission et on nous a requis
pour des personnes qui étaient bloquées
dans un véhicule ouais donc c'est un peu
tout le monde est débordé dame au petit
matin le calme est revenu sur le port
c'est l'heure du nettoyage chez les
commerçants mais la rochelle est sonné
certains bateaux n'ont pas résisté et
par endroits la chaussée s'est envolé et
dans une quinzaine de communes de
charente maritime
les habitants ont les pieds dans l'eau
alors en vendée la pluie et les vents
violents ont provoqué une montée des
eaux très rapide conséquence au moins
cinq morts et des communes inondées
arnaud compte en quelques minutes les
rues se sont transformées en torrents en
crue surpris dans leur sommeil les
habitants parfois été contraint de se
barricader chez eux ou de se réfugier
sur les toits en attendant les pompiers
on s'est levé on a regardé par la
fenêtre on a vu qu'ils avaient le dos
non qu'on a prévenu bas tous les voisins
sur les communes situés en front de mer
le niveau de l'eau atteint parfois un
mètre vingt dans la nuit et dans
l'urgence 240 personnes ont été
secourues
le plus souvent porté à dos d'homme
avant d'être mises à l'abri
tu es monté très vite très vite très
très très très vite
en l'espace de quoi un quart d'heure
c'était incroyable on est sorti par la
fenêtre et on a nagé jusqu'à chez les
voisins hélas tous les meubles
flottaient on a déposé les deux enfants
sur sur un canapé pour qu'il soit hors
de l'eau et nous on a attendu en fait
que les pompiers il ya une cherchons l'a
appelé les pompiers sont venus chercher
j'ai cru à un moment donné qui avait
plus de toit qui avait de l'eau qui
tombait dans la maison qui en entendant
le bruit de l'eau et je me suis levée et
ce en me levant que j'ai vu qu'il y
avait ces cinq centimètres d'eau partie
lots rentrer par la fenêtre par les
portes malgré les nombreux secouristes
déployés sur le terrain la tempête a
fait plusieurs victimes
cinq personnes sont mortes noyées au sud
des sables d'olonne dans un secteur très
localisées sur les communes de
la-faute-sur-mer et de
l'aiguillon-sur-mer un bilan hélas
provisoire le nombre des victimes n'est
absolument pas estimable pour l'instant
puisque ça augmenté en une heure en
était le premier noyer mais était
signalé à 9 heures et les maintenant 10
heures nous en sommes déjà à cinq corps
l'alerté rouge a été levée ce matin sur
la vendée où 80 % des communes sont
privés d'électricité
la vendée est donc le département le
plus violemment touchés par cette
tempête
avec deux villages qui sont ce soir en
partie submergée gerra griesbeck karine
comme a dit johann nertomb la vendée et
ce soir une région sinistrée vision de
désolation la tempête n'a épargné
personne
on compte les blessés par dizaines mais
aussi les morts dans le village de
l'aiguillon sur mer
une digue a cédé et regardez là on a
plus de vélo il ya plus retenu la digue
l'aele et koupèla et là maintenant bel
olo de mer va rentrer dans les 10 dans
les habitations
toute la journée des maisons ont été
évacuées avec les moyens du bord
des centaines de pompiers de gendarmes
ont été mobilisés avec des renforts de
la sécurité civile s'est monté très vite
très vite
très très très très vite en l'espace de
quoi un quart d'heure
c'était incroyable on est sorti par la
fenêtre et on a nagé jusqu'à chez les
voisins hélas tous les meubles
flottaient les deux communes les plus
touchées sont celles de la faute-sur-mer
et de l'aiguillon-sur-mer où la digue a
cédé le problème de la que la mer monte
d'un mètre d'une seule fois donc nom
vient de la surcote mais il ya un
phénomène que je peux pas vous expliquer
imaginez vous un mètre devant vous qui
s'avance et
qui ravagent tout vision d'horreur les
vents violents se sont conjugués à une
marée de fort coefficient
personne n'imaginait un tel déluge on
n'a jamais vu ça à quoi on se croirait
dans un film c'est horrible on n'a pas
vu le truc venir quoi c'est monté
tellement vite que ben voilà on n'a rien
pu faire
on a appelé les pompiers mais ils ont
débordé de partout donc ce soir
rien n'est réglé chacun cherche encore
des nouvelles de ses proches
j'attends que ont soufflé par an je
comprends pas depuis 4 heures ce matin
bonjour papa ça va ils sont bloqués dans
leur dans leur m'en sers depuis 4 heures
ce matin ils sont pas secourus non cola
je suis très inquiète très inquiète
parce qu'on m'a dit que la halle à
marées à les remonter
donc ils ont pu électricité plus rien
sur plus de 70 ans
les secours ont encore reçu des renforts
il se prépare à passer une nuit
supplémentaire alors que s'annonce une
nouvelle grande marée certains villages
sinistrés sont coupés du monde plus
d'eau ni d'électricité et des routes
impraticables reportage à loix en ré
antoine gaveau bernard von arb
aujourd'hui les pompiers sont les seuls
à pouvoir emprunter cette route ou ce
qu'il en reste
sur l'île de ré la tempête a fait lâcher
de digues
la mère a envahi la terre et couper
certains habitants du reste du monde
alors voyez une voiture d'avoir pu voter
dont côté de l'arrière elles le font
remonter devant plusieurs vagues géantes
cette nuit et une partie du petit
village de loi est englouti jamais vu ça
même mon père 81
sept ans donc il a dit que non ils
avaient vu une ira un peu plus loin mais
jamais jusqu'ici dégâts matériels et
catastrophe économique pour les éleveurs
d'huitres nombreux sur l'île j'ai pu de
cabanes ostréicoles tout matériel est
sous l'eau est bon mais pas qu'on n'a
pas pu aller voir baisser taupe est beau
et bon bah voilà où est plus travaillé
non là c'est le gagner il a je crois que
je vais arrêter complètement parce que
c'est le moral il est plus du tout là et
l'électricité est ce qu'on sait c'est
plus d'électricité plus d'eau non plus
les habitants attendent la décrue et
s'organise avec les moyens du bord se
débrouille comme on peut en apprendre a
pas d'électricité on a des réserves et
nos congélateurs forcément ils vont on
va réviser pour faire à manger pour pour
se chauffer et puis voilà sur l'île de
ré on annonce à nouveau des marais
importante pour les prochains jours cet
isolement pourrait donc durer toute la
semaine
madame monsieur bonsoir ce 19/20 sera en
grande partie consacrée à la tempête en
france qui a fait entre 45 et 50 morts
selon le ministre de l'intérieur voyez
ces images aériennes des communes les
plus touchées en vendée on mesure le
caractère exceptionnel de cette tempête
une catastrophe nationale a déclaré tout
à l'heure le premier ministre
nicolas sarkozy se rendra sur place
demain près de 50 morts un bilan
toujours provisoire qui ne cesse de
s'alourdir au fil des heures la sécurité
civile ne cache pas son inquiétude à
cause des marées il y a encore des
risques ce soir nous partons
immédiatement à la faute-sur-mer en
vendée une station balnéaire en deuil
vingt-sept personnes ont perdu la vie
sans compter les disparus
elisabeth beney dans ce lotissement de
la faute sur mer au sud de la vendée
les pompiers se relaient depuis ce matin
pour sauver les habitants
on sait déjà que le bilan est très lourd
vingt-sept personnes au moins sont
mortes
prisonnière de la montée des eaux elles
ont atteint par endroits 2 mètres 50
les habitants racontent comment ils ont
été surpris dans leur sommeil par la
rapidité et la violence de la tempête
je me suis aperçu en mettant le pied par
terre qu'il y avait un petit peu un
petit peu d'eau et le temps de réveiller
tout le monde de récupérer genre les
papiers enfin bon certains documents
téléphone
on est monté à l'étagé puis la porte a
cédé et en l'espace d'une demi-heure
la maison s'est remplie les pompiers ont
pu se courir 600 personnes mais
plusieurs habitants sont encore coincés
à les tâches de leur maison j'attends
que ont soufflé par an je comprends pas
là depuis 4 heures ce matin bonjour papa
ça va ils sont bloqués dans leur malheur
m'en sers depuis 4 heures ce matin ils
sont pas secourus non cola je suis très
inquiète très inquiète parce qu'on m'a
dit que la halle à marées à les remonter
donc ils ont pu électricité plus rien
sur plus de 70 ans la plupart des
habitants ont pu être évacués dans un
gymnase d'une commune voisine qui
s'apprête à les recevoir
les pompiers poursuivre leurs opérations
de pompage mais des risques d'inondation
subsistent avec une grande marée
attendue ce soir autres départements
particulièrement touchés par la tempête
la chante maritime qui elle aussi avait
été placé par météo france en alerte
rouge
au total cinq personnes sont décédées
dont un enfant de 10 ans ici aussi il a
fallu l'intervention d'hélicoptères pour
récupérer des habitants menacés par la
montée brutale des eaux
aurélie rl
l'hélitreuillage seul moyen pour
atteindre ce qui se retrouve prisonnier
des eaux
mais les pompiers sont débordés plus de
50 cm d'eau dans les rues alors on
s'entraide entre voisins eux sont venus
au secours de cette personne âgée est
hors de l'eau en show bien après ben moi
je suis retourné chez moi j'te faute des
vents allant jusqu'à 120 km heure ont
soufflé à la rochelle dès 2h cette nuit
la mer est démontée et les bateaux se
retrouvent coq les voitures quel que
soit le véhicule tout déplacement
devient compliqué en fait c'est très
dangereuse qu'on a surtout peur des
bouches d'égout c'est pas trop en marche
robin c'est assez inquiétant jamais vu
d'aussi haute n'a jamais bu l'eau
atteint ce niveau là au matin les
habitants se retrouvent les pieds dans
l'eau et constate les dégâts
alors des machines à laver ou elle est
née à 4 heures je suis sorti y avait
rien fait à 5 heures j'ai 50 60 cm 2 2
dans quoi ça s'est produit
oui d'un seul coup et surmonté d'un seul
coup sur l'île de ré difficile de
rejoindre le continent et de traverser
l'île les routes sont totalement inondés
une tempête sans précédent couplée à un
fort coefficient de marée les digues
n'ont pas résisté
lillers paix en 2000 où en plus on est
on a plus de défenses nos digues et en
étant cassé la mer va rentrer chez nous
dans le village deux fois par jour
chaque maillot et c'est des gros
coefficients qui arrive
dans cette cellule de crise on gère
l'urgence de nombreux habitants ont
besoin de secours
six lieux d'hébergement ont été mis en
place dans le département
autre image de la tempête en provenance
de nos stations régionales le récit de
véronique gens des rafales à 110 km
heure sous l'assaut du vent et des
vagues
la mer est passé par dessus une digue
cayeux-sur-mer dans la somme l'eau s'est
arrêté à 20 mètres seulement de cette
maison quand ça arrive on a peur qu'on
ne consomme que les dégâts sont
considérables
ici à tour la toiture d'une école s'est
tout simplement envolé à loudun dans la
vienne
la cheminée de cette maison s'est
effondrée sur la propriétaire grièvement
blessé dans la cheminée est partie des
2e étage cela partait extérieure du
bâtiment et la traversière premier étage
et est arrivé au rez-de-chaussée sur le
lit où la dame dormait tant que cette
semaine l'idée est tombé sur ses ventes
inférieure
les stations de ski des pyrénées ont été
particulièrement touchés les rafales ont
atteint 200 km heure par endroits
certaines risquent de ne pas rouvrir
cette saison autre conséquence du
passage de la tempête des milliers
d'arbres déracinés des lignes
électriques à terre et en millions de
foyers privés d'électricité un peu
partout dans l'hexagone mais certains
usagers ont tout simplement allumer des
bougies et l'ont pris avec philosophie
c'est la graverie fait pas froid
y'a pas un temps de chien il n'y a pas
de neige
on devra patienter ça va revenir
j'espère selon edf 2700 agents
travaillent au rétablissement des lignes
des renforts sont prévues pour demain le
retour à la normale prendra plusieurs
jours
les zones où le réseau électrique et le
plus endommagé la france n'avait pas
connu une catastrophe naturelle aussi
meurtrière depuis plus de dix ans le
bilan du passage de la tempête xynthia
et ce soir de 51 morts huit personnes
sont toujours portées disparues symbole
de l'ampleur de cette catastrophe de
petit village de vendée
l'aiguillon-sur-mer et la faute-sur-mer
and charline anbar depuis la tempête les
deux communes de son plus sûr mais sous
la mer l'océan a envahi les terres au
moins 33 personnes ont péri en vendée le
bilan est lourd et provisoire pour
s'assurer que d'autres victimes ne sont
pas à déplorer
trois cent cinquante sauveteurs et 250
gendarmes ont inspecté maison après
maison
si free wheels et à manger donc à
personne et c'est pas sûr c'est pas sûr
mais ça nous donne déjà des éléments
rien à signaler la maison est tagué mais
sous l'eau les recherches sont
difficiles
normalement de des morceaux de bois de
toutes les voitures donc
se cogner qui peu partout pas si par
endroits la décrue a commencé
elle révèle des terrains et des maisons
ravagées par un bond du sein
[Musique]
ça met de l'eau chicala on avait deux
petits enfants
fort heureusement que mon fils était là
et il a pu avec sa femme
on porte les deux petits-enfants et donc
que deux en roupies 5 ans et demi et
nous on n'a pas s'être ailleurs le mur
on aime une échelle on a passé chez le
voisin face aux nerfs qui lâchent
face à l'ampleur de la tâche des
entreprises locales offrent gratuitement
leur aide
les bras remplis les particuliers
affluent vers le gymnase nourriture
vêtements et couvertures
on va essayer vide à plat les armoires
avec des choses propres
on est ici parce que notre coeur nous
appelle à venir là devant la détresse
des vendéens la solidarité affluent sur
les 765 personnes qui se sont retrouvées
sans toit plus de 700 ont trouvé un abri
chez un ami ou un voisin
[Musique]